[Music] I'm about to throw up oh you bet - hell not get his hands stitch leather you better drink it Mike Mike relax bust if you make a hole sorry you are Papa it's so interesting when you come back together on a movie after this long there's such a deep love for these characters and for this franchise [Music] [Applause] the first one was 23 years ago which sounds crazy well I'm a lot heavier I love 1 & 2 I just wanted to get back with you again to do it because people need to see us again on camera yeah we made the characters real you ready to bust this case open yeah let's finish strong and in 3 they gonna want to just ride with us the yin in the yin and the yang absolutely it's rare but is beautiful to be able to come back together and everybody's still handsome that's why we have chemistry because you say it's nothing like that [Laughter] [Music]